so what we had here was a problem of the  belief that women of color were a  category in and of themselves they could  not represent themselves nor could they  represent all women are all men and this  is the moment when I really started  thinking about pre-existing schemas  you've heard about the story the father  who rushes his son to the hospital the  surgeon begins to operate and then  realizes oh no I can't it's my son and  you know everyone's stumped by this how  can the father you know Rush him to the  hospital and the surgeon says he's my  son too until it hits you duh the  surgeon is a woman takes that extra  moment for it to lock into place now  just add into that race class any other  kind of schema that takes even longer  for it to lock in that your pre-existing  assumptions about who this person was  um we're all wrong that's the space for  intersectionality